au sommaire le sentier littoral nord en
vtt entre le port de sainte-marie et le
phare de sainte-suzanne la curiosité de
la semaine le domaine du grand hazier
pour se rendre sur la partie est du
sentier littoral nord qui court jusqu'à
l'embouchure de la rivière
sainte-suzanne
il existe plusieurs entrées pour la
randonnée d'aujourd'hui le port de
sainte-marie et notre point de départ
pour cette randonnée de 16 km en aller
retour et sans dénivelé prévoir de quoi
vous ravitailler ou protéger du soleil
et de la pluie et le nécessaire de
réparation de vtt
j'aime la réunion je respecte et
préserve sa nature exceptionnelle
construit dans les années 90 le petit
port de pêche et de plaisance de
sainte-marie abrite près de 200 bateaux
et quelques commerces pour des
vététistes plus habitué aux chemins en
sous-bois faire ses premiers tours de
roue sous l'oeil des pêcheurs est plutôt
amusant avant de filer vers sainte
suzanne on peut découvrir un autre
chemin qui ne fait pas partie de la
couronne littorale le long du grillage
qui protège la zone aéroportuaire cette
large ou à bétonner conduit jusqu'à 1
sentiers méconnus en bord de mer d'ici
le point de vue est idéal pour s'adonner
aux joies du sporting autrement dit voir
décoller ou atterrir les avions de ligne
ce jour là c'est même toute une équipe
qui est venue filmer cet atterrissage
pour les besoins d'un film
la piste se termine en cul de sac près
de l'embouchure de la rivière des pluies
de retour au port il est temps de
récupérer l'ancienne route nationale
aujourd'hui condamnés en direction de
l'est
arrivé au centre de sainte marie c'est
l'occasion de refaire ses réserves d'eau
même si la balade est facile il faut
quand même penser à bien s'hydrater
quand le sentier littoral redevient une
piste il emprunte alors le tracé de
l'ancienne voie de chemin de fer
démantelés depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années
il reste certaines traces de son
existence comme ce véritable tunnel
d'arbres à l'ombre desquels on peut
faire de belles rencontres
cette partie roulante et bien aménagé et
la plus fréquentée car elle se situe en
contrebas du quartier moderne de la
convenance joggeurs et cyclistes s'y
croisent régulièrement même si comme
partout la cohabitation peut parfois
être délicate passée la ravine des
chèvres
le säntis et plus sauvage et sillonne le
long des champs de canne malgré la
présence de nombreuses propriétés
privées les aménageurs ont réussi à
trouver des solutions pour faire passer
un sentier officiel véritable outil au
service du bien-être de la population
le sentier littoral mériterait de se
prolonger sur la plus grande partie de
l'île
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui et pas seulement à cause du
relief
au bout du sentier le tunnel marque le
passage vers un autre monde
le retour à la ville sur le front de mer
de sainte suzanne au dessus du tunnel
le phare classé monument historique
depuis l'année dernière est le seul qui
reste dans l'île il matérialise
aujourd'hui la fin de notre randonnée
je vous ai amené sur ce sentier là parce
que c'est un sentier à tout faire c'est
un très bon moyen de sortir du chef-lieu
est d'aller regarder les alentours c'est
un sentier très facile ce sens et sur
lequel on peut venir en famille avec les
enfants c'est vraiment la balade du
dimanche
et puis on peut la saucisse au nez à sa
mesure
si on a envie d'aller jusqu'à 5500 y en
aura jusqu'à cette finale sur le vix
s'arrêter à bois madame après être passé
à la jamaïque simple à régler les petits
pois on peut aussi on peut aller un
petit peu plus loin on périodicité le
le phare de sainte-suzanne ce que j'aime
moins sur ce sentier c'est la
cohabitation est obligatoire entre les
joggeurs les vététistes et dames avec
lui poussait et c'est parce que ça
demande un comportement
citoyen que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément il ya un code du ve et éthique
à respecter si on veut si on veut
continuer à profiter de ce sentier là il
faut vraiment que tout le monde se
côtoie en bonne intelligence
au bout d'une allée de pamiers cette
vieille bâtisse créole classé monument
historique a servi de décor à de
nombreux films le domaine du grand
hazier et notre curiosité de la semaine
nous sommes au domaine du grand hazier
en 1903 c'est mon grand père qui
achètent ici donc ça appartient la
famille chassaigne depuis 110 ans en dix
ans après avoir habité l'ancienne maison
il va reconstruire la maison actuelle
avec une structure métallique c'est pour
ça qu'elle est inscrite aux monuments
historiques
évidemment elle est habillée de bois
mais c'est la première maison privée
quoi structure métallique la maison
évidemment il ya du mobilier de l'époque
de ce que bon mais le grand père a vécu
en 1900 mais il a acheté aussi des
meubles d'occasion donc où on a dû
mobilier compagnie des indes qui à 250
300 ans
moi ce qui m'intéresse le plus dans la
maison c'est toute la paperasse quoi
donc bien que j'ai pas connu
physiquement mon grand père ben je
connais grâce à tout ce qu'il a laissé
comme écrit sans hâte historiens on
apprécie de consulter ce genre de
documents et de faire profiter aux
autres quoi